[Musique]
saint-andré en bresse offre une plongée
dans le temps un voyage dans la
paysannerie bressane entre le 17e et le
20e siècle au temps où les habitants
vivaient en autosuffisance sur leur
ferme ou les hommes et les animaux
vivaient tous proches au rythme des
saisons le domaine plus saunier c'est
vrai est assez typique sur un même site
vous avez déjà plusieurs siècles de
construction et surtout des bâtiments
qui sont agencés selon un format assez
typique en bresse vous avez sûrement à
gauche ici des bâtiments plutôt réservé
à l'habitat des exploitants et à ma
droite des bâtiments des berges âge pour
les animaux même s'il n'est plus
agricole aujourd'hui le lieu vit
toujours il compte un gîte de groupe
entièrement restauré par la communauté
de communes est un espace muséal animé
par l'écomusée de la bresse dans cette
bâtisse la plus ancienne du site
soubassement pour protéger de l'humidité
du sol toiture pentu en petites briques
charpente et colombages en chaîne et des
briques pour combler l'ossature bois
toute la typicité de l'habitat bressan
s'offre en un seul regard avec cette
petite coquetterie en plus les galeries
qui témoigne de l'aisance des
propriétaires
les bressans utiliser les matériaux
disponibles autour d'eux pour construire
leur maison qu'ils n'avaient qu'à se
pencher pour récupérer l'argile pour en
faire là dessus il ou d
des briques et le bois récupéré le
fameux chaîne de bourgogne qu'on voit à
peu près dans toute la région
[Musique]
s'il est une ferme bressane connu dans
le monde entier c'est bien celle de
marie eugénie dupuis
sept propriétaires de chambres d'hôtes
ne compte plus les tournages télé les
articles de journaux ou les mentions
dans les guides touristiques consacrer à
sa maison une notoriété qui doit
beaucoup aux quinze mois de rénovation
menée par marie eugénie et son mari rien
ripoliné ici ils ont apporté tout le
confort moderne sans sacrifier
l'authenticité des lieux les volets
n'ont pas dû être changé depuis les
années 20 30 peut-être même avant moi
c'est toujours les même volé
des petites ouvertures de pour aérer le
grenier comme le grenier rester à
grenier l'été d'ouverture tout simple
avec des trois briques on les voit plus
nulle parce que tout le monde a restauré
pour faire moderne et moi est existe
encore là c'est la ccit plein de petits
détails comme ça que l'on trouve tout au
tout le long tout le long de cette
maison on sait ça fait partie de son
charme un
mari au génie a l'habitude de dire que
sa maison de famille et comme son
sixième enfant un bébé qu'elle a entouré
de beaucoup de soin mais qui le lui rend
bien
cette maison elle représente en fait
tous un peu toute ma vie même si je suis
parisienne j'ai toujours su que j'étais
bien ici voilà je vais assez pierre
vient de ce que tous les frais c'est ce
qu'on a fait avec mon mari ici en
quelques années pour la rendre
accueillant parce que par exemple de
savoir ce que la nature autour les
arbres par mois quand je suis arrivé ici
tous les armes c'est moi qui les ai
planté donc voilà ça laisse derrière soi
une petite trace voilà avec des odeurs
de poulet du gâteau au chocolat
une ferme bressane qui a plus de 200 ans
d'histoire et qui n'a pas fini de voir
défiler du monde
mario jean denis souhaite partager
encore longtemps sa maison passion avec
sa famille ni ses amis et les touristes
de passage